One small step for man,
one giant leap for Finch Weinberg.
Hello. We have Caleb Landry Jones as Jeff.
He had to wear these huge stilts,
all this other CGI friendly stuff.
We used Mo-Cap, a Moven suit, which is
a suit that records all of your movements.
There's a hand-off
between the Legacy puppeteers
who are starting the evolution
of the artificial intelligence,
and then visual effects takes over
by having a bunch of animators
and Caleb as an actor
evolving the artificial intelligence.
So, Legacy, they've built a robot that's
the most complex robot they've ever built.
There is enormous amount of parts
that were created for these puppets.
Jeff was really very different
from other robots that we've done
in the past with let's bring him
and ground him in the real world.
So his head is the top
of a welding gas tank.
A lot of his body parts, it's all chipped.
There's a lot of different textures.
It was very important that we actually
had a physical robot on set.
Once Jeff becomes a fully formed
robot, Caleb then takes over.
It was good to make sure
that before you had Jeff become a fully CG
character, that you introduce
a character to the audience
that is grounded in reality
and in the real world.
When I saw it recently,
I didn't remember Caleb in costume.
I was just seeing Jeff as Jeff,
a testament, I think, to
how fluid Caleb was inside all of that.
You can't really get the nuances
of what happens on set,
if it was just a CG thing
that worked perfectly every single time.
There's this amazing creature
that's not part of our normal life,
but that's just kind of this horror to tell a very, very human story.